jusqu'à l'été dernier jean marie lise
houle tu étais responsable de la
paroisse de dreux aujourd'hui il n'est
plus curé mais toujours prêtre et il a
choisi de se tourner vers l'écologie
l'idée a germé avec le film demain de
cyril dion puis s'est développé avec la
crise sanitaire c'est vrai que pendant
le premier confinement le retravailler
le texte du pape françois sur l'écologie
intégral lahoud est aussi ça m'a
vraiment ça m'a boosté enfin ça va ça à
déclencher quoi en temps mais c'est vrai
que c'est vrai qu'il faut agir il faut
faire quelque chose il a donc troqué sa
soutane contre des bots et a monté un
projet collectif baptisé grâce au jardin
sur ces 7 hectares les premiers arbres
commencent à être plantés d arbres dont
on peut manger les feuilles les fruits
ou les racines aujourd'hui les êtres
humains nous nous nourrissions à peu
près avec 60 espèces différentes de
végétaux et dans la création il y en a
sept mille qui peuvent se nourrir et
donc l'idée de la forêt comestibles
c'est de ré apprendre à nourrir avec ce
qu'il ya dans la forêt
cette fois ci les plans de pâques a nié
et néflier sont mises en terre par
l'équipe du restaurant étoilé de
chartres un restaurant qui soutiendra le
projet sur la durée jean marie m'a quand
même un triller par rapport au fait de
découvrir des nouvelles soeur avec cette
forêt comme est-il donc moi c'est
quelque chose qui m'intéressait lorient
si le prêtre a su convaincre c'est parce
qu'il s'y connaît il est titulaire d'un
bac agricole et d'un bts horticulture
paysage surtout son projet composé de
cinq jardins et vergers viendra aussi
aider des associations et personnes en
difficulté y aura un chantier
d'insertion dans la production des
légumes et voilà il y aura aussi de
l'insertion sociale dans le jardin de
proximité avec les restos du coeur
puisque c'est permettre à des gens qui
sont aidés par les restos du coeur de
cultiver leurs légumes avec 6700 arbres
et arbustes a planté le projet devrait
commencer à porter ses fruits en 2024